[Music]
ladies and gentlemen good afternoon
please welcome Sudhir hasbi hello
everybody I'm Severus Bay I'm the
director of product for data analytics
and GCP thank you for coming to this
session I know it's just after lunch or
around lunchtime so I hope I am NOT
going to bore you too much in this
session we'll keep it exciting so let's
get started with the session the key
thing is most of the folks in in the
audience or outside know Google from
this search box and the first experience
people have with Google is what are the
search box search for a term and you get
some interesting and and results that
you're looking for actually behind the
scenes when you search for anything on
on on the on the search box there's lot
of infrastructure there's lot of
analytics that's going on we are one of
the largest organization that collects
massive amounts of data and analyzes it
and uses that it's not just search
though if you look at it we have more
than seven products and I know I heard
in keynote earlier today we may have an
eight to one with Drive which will hit 8
billion users active users monthly going
forward the key here is big data is in
our DNA we leverage data we leverage
machine learning for giving those
amazing experiences in all of these
products and the way we do that is
through internal technology that we have
built if you think about dremel which we
use internally for all our analytics
bigquery is actually an enterprise
version of that same piece of technology
that's available for enterprises so what
we are doing here is bringing the
technology that we have invested over
ears and making it available for our
customers in the cloud if you think
about it data across the world is
growing it will be about 163 zettabytes
by 2025 and as datasets grow within
organizations you want to have
infrastructure you want to have
analytics capability that can actually
process that amount of data
just a data point one of our customers
really when they started their their
data collection and their streaming
analytics pipelines they used to collect
like 50 million events a day now they
are up to 5 billion within 18 months so
what happens is as you start seeing
value from your data you will collect
more and more but you want ability and
infrastructure that can actually
seamlessly scale as your needs grow
within your organization's similarly
there was a survey done MIT survey was
done about machine learning and AI how
many customers are using it how it was
going that the key thing was the
organizations that are actually using AI
are able to make 2x faster decisions 5x
faster decisions they are able to do 2
times more data-driven decisions within
the organizations and also 3x faster
execution on the decisions that they are
making so overall if you think about it
machine learning AI is going to be
critical for all your organization's and
then the key point though is if your
organization is not Gruder at analytics
it's never going to be great at AI so
the first thing the foundation your you
have to have great foundation on
analytics data how do you process data
how do you analyze data and then you can
think about how you go ahead and do
machine learning on top of that data
leverage AI for for differentiation if
you look at the numbers though less than
1% of world's unstructured data is
actually being used for analytics or
analysis analysis today less than 50% of
structured data is analyzed today within
organizations so what is our approach to
this if you look at Google what are we
doing there are four key things one we
are focusing on infrastructure or or
solutions that allow you to go ahead and
focus on analytics not infrastructure we
will talk more about that the second is
developing comprehensive solutions so we
know customers need the whole portfolio
of solutions to go ahead and do analysis
we are focusing on end to end all the
components that you need into an ml
lifecycle and we'll look at that quickly
and then innovative and open our being
an open cloud making sure you have
options with open source so
so that you can go ahead and and run the
workloads the way you want to run is
super critical for us and we have lot of
investments that we do in making sure we
have a promote that let's talk about
what does focusing on analytic means and
not on infrastructure if you think about
us if you're doing analysis with
bigquery which is our data a cloud scale
data warehousing product you can get
started within seconds you basically can
bring your datasets and start analyzing
instantly the key thing is if you're not
using a service product like like
bigquery or data flow you will have to
worry about monitoring you have to worry
about performance tuning infrastructure
how many nodes do I need what kind of
cluster size do I need how do you
performance tune none of that is going
to be a problem if you're focused on
server less so that's what our focus is
we want to provide you with
infrastructure that automatically scales
gives you ability to do analysis and you
don't have to worry about anything just
bring your data start doing analysis on
it let's talk about the second point
right who end-to-end comprehensive
solutions the big thing is if you think
about analysis it actually starts with
ingestion how do I get my data the first
step is how do I get my streaming data
we have lots of customers using massive
amount of streaming events that are
coming to them and how do you scale this
infrastructure seamlessly so cloud
pub/sub is our solution that allows you
to do millions of events per second that
you can collect and do analysis on them
similarly lot of our customers use
different Google products like for
example Adwords and double-click and all
of those for advertising purposes what
we have done is we made it really easy
for customers who want to use Google
Cloud for marketing analytics within few
clicks you can literally go ahead and
get your AdWords data your double-click
data into bigquery for analysis
seamlessly similarly IOT is super
critical you saw some amazing
announcements today morning with HT PU
and on cloud IOT core we have cloud IOT
core so if you are interested in
collecting IOT data you can seamlessly
collect that and actually leverage the
whole platform from that so we have
covered the ingestion
if you think about reliable data
processing and streaming pipelines we
have multiple options for customers
right one is data flow with beam so beam
and open so is an open source sdk for
you to build batch and streaming
pipelines with the same programming
model you can use data flow which allows
you to automatically scale build
large-scale data processing pipelines
great for developers but we also realize
that lot of our customers have in-house
capabilities which spark an Hadoop and
they love SPARC I used to use SPARC
before in my previous roles so I love
spark too so for that we have managed
Hadoop and spark environment with data
proc and then for analysts and we know a
lot of our analyst community which is
familiar with data also wants to do data
wrangling also wants to do data
preparation so that they know best
before the data is used what kind of
analysis they want to do and clean up
the data so we have cloud data prep for
for those those audience after that once
your data is ready you want to do
analysis at scale you want to build your
data lakes you can actually use GCS
Google Cloud Storage to go ahead and put
all your structured unstructured data
and then process it or you can use our
cloud scale data warehouse with bigquery
to put all this data at petabyte scale
and then do analysis on top of it and
once you have analysis platform ready
for you then for advanced analytics you
can use ml engine you can use tensorflow
for visualizations you can use data
studio we'll see some of the new
enhancements where we are making
available on that and also sheets lot of
our customers especially G suite
customers who use sheets every day we
are making some enhancements on that to
easily make data from bigquery and other
places available today so that's there
if you think about ml lifecycle this is
the whole lifecycle right you have ml
lifecycle is you start from ingestion
you have to explore you have to prepare
you have to pre-process then you start
the process of training hyper tuning
testing and predictions there's a whole
lifecycle that has to happen and what we
provide is a whole suite of products
that allow you to go to every one of
those processes but what we are also
doing it make
it very easy for you to do machine
learning and you heard some of the
announcements we did earlier today and I
will go a bit more detail into that and
actually we have an amazing demo for you
later in the in the session from a
customer momentum perspective that's our
portfolio we have seen tremendous growth
in the data analytics side with our
customers lot of customers using the
whole portfolio across industry
verticals from financial services to
retail from gaming to media
entertainment all all across the board
manufacturing all across the board we
are seeing tremendous growth in our data
analytics capability being used in
different organizations and it's across
the different sizes of data sets - so
you heard earlier today Twitter Tata
talked about moving their large-scale
Hadoop deployment I think he I think it
was mentioned 300 petabytes of data
being moved into GCP and running that
scale of cluster and the highlight was
like our network and our capability that
we provide with a networking stack
allows you to have this decoupling of
storage and compute that really makes it
easy to manage the whole environment
reduce the costs and all so we are
seeing tremendous growth with folks like
Twitter Yahoo's of the world but also
lot of enterprise customers that are
that are using using the platform so
with that let me invite Irene Omar who
is the deputy CEO for the AirAsia on the
stage to talk more about this
I already know you hi thank you ah can
you just do a quick introduction about
you your role and tell us a bit more
about AirAsia sure area is the largest
low-cost carrier in Asia so we started
back in 2001 we've just two aircraft we
carried about about 20,000 passengers
and now 16 years later we have over 230
Agra off and over the years we have
carried over 500 million passengers and
this year we're looking about 19 million
passengers that were carrying per year
so we've grown very fast we have bases
in Southeast Asia Southeast Asia ASEAN
is our backyard and the reason why we're
focused in building that market base
because it has over 600 million
population base the third largest after
China and India and it has a very young
population base with about a median age
of 28 29 years old 50% of the population
is under 30 70% is under 40 50 percent
of the population is live in urban areas
and it's one of the fastest-growing GDP
in the world and one of the fastest
growing middle income earners in the
world so this is where as a low-cost
care is fantastic opportunity to grow as
a population and if you look at the
geographical landscape of Southeast Asia
it's surrounded by water and and that's
where we feel there's a lot of
opportunity to learn about the
population to grow further and build
other business opportunities apart from
just running an airline so tremendous
growth rate within two to three years
from two planes to 230 I guess now what
were the key challenges you're facing
and then tell us more about what were
the business challenges and how are you
using Google cloud for some of those I
think the key challenge is because we
have operations in various countries
Malaysia Thailand Indonesia Philippines
and recently in India and also Japan and
we're looking at getting data from all
over from various systems or so forth
basically so we have data coming from
our booking system 80% of our book
goes through our internet and our mobile
app unlike other airlines which is the
other way around and then we have data
coming from our aircraft and from our
engines and we use our aircraft in in in
the most efficient and we maximize a
protect the utilization rate the a320
that we use we fly 14 hours a day and we
have 25 minutes turnaround so that we
can fit in as many sectors as we can so
if you look at the whole group is about
departing flights is about 1500 per day
and we're looking at departing
passengers about almost 300 thousand
today so there's a lot of data coming
there and it's really important when you
are running an efficient operations you
need it to be precise and you need
something that's scalable and accurate
so that we'll be able to understand
those data better and be able to focus
more on serving our consumers better so
the data that we need is really more on
how do we improve the consumers
experience and the revenue that we can
get from them and be able to provide the
right kind of products and offerings for
them and how do we use this data to
improve the overall operational
efficiency of our operations and so that
we reach productivity in the most
efficient way and be able to focus more
of our efforts into looking at the
insights of not only just our operations
but also the behavior of our consumers
so we can provide better products
offerings and so forth got it and I know
you use bigquery and data studio and all
the other tools in Google cloud are
there key metrics you can share with us
that have been having like where you're
seen really
growth or savings that can you share
with some of the things so I'm also in
charge of digital transformation so the
key thing is for us to integrate all
this data coming from various sources
and to be able to combine those data and
make meaningful algorithm out of it and
what we have found even though we only
probably use less than 20% of the data
that we have already combined is that
the
rate of the revenues or consumer has
doubled and that you know every one
percent conversion rate actually
increased a revenue by about fifty
million u.s. dollars and so forth and
what we have seen also because we're
able to predict better in to some
operations in terms of maintenance and
so forth
we reduce the number of aircraft on
ground and that means it's better
experience for passengers and so forth
and we have seen that the cost has
probably reduced by at least ten percent
or so and that's actually quite big in
our operations of running an airline
that's amazing especially in airline
where they as you said the operational
cost is heavy so ten percent saving
doubling the conversion rate and you're
just using twenty percent of the data
yes so probably a little bit less than
that because we just started only about
a few years a couple of years ago and
that's a lot to do so it's very key to
be able to streamline all those in
bigquery and it's a powerful tool that
allows us to be scalable and be able to
work faster and be more focused on the
requirements of our consumers and so
forth yeah that's great thank you thanks
a lot awesome results and I'm looking
forward to what we can do together as
you get to 20 to 30 to 100% of the data
as you start analyzing it thank you
thank you very much
so that's about now AirAsia let's talk
about there are four key areas that we
have we focus on normally when we talk
to our customers when when they're using
the the different portfolio of solution
that we have one is a of course
modernizing the data warehouses and
we'll talk more about that analyzing
streaming data which is super critical
as organizations are collecting massive
amounts of events event data from
different places clickstream to IOT
devices streaming is streaming data and
processing streaming data is super
critical in organizations running open
source software and of course
visualizing and and using the data in a
visual manner is critical for
organizations let's talk about bigquery
for a second
bigquery is actually cloud scale data
warehouse it's a natively built if you
haven't read Dremel paper you should
check it out
it's ground-up build data warehouse from
the scratch it's cloud scale you can do
petabyte scale queries within seconds
it's support standard sequel you can
actually get started with it at no cost
there is a free tier that's available
how many of you actually use bigquery
here great that a lot of people who
don't so my recommendation would be you
should go check it out it will take you
couple of minutes to go actually bring
your data in and start analyzing as I
said completely server lists you don't
have to worry about infrastructure bring
data in and start analyzing that's the
key thing it's highly secure it's we
encrypt the data at rest it's highly
available and then real-time streaming
is native to bigquery you can stream
hundreds of thousands of events directly
into bigquery and then actually analyze
it in at the same time so that's super
critical so one of the announcements you
heard today morning was Rajan talking
about bigquery ml the key thing in this
was the two big challenges we started
hearing from our customers was it's
great to use bigquery massive amount of
data bring all the data in but if you
want to do any machine learning you have
to move that data out and then if you
have seen some numbers like 80% of data
scientists spend time in data
preparation moving data around and doing
testing of the of the models and also
our thing was how do you reduce that
time by making machine learning
available in the data warehouse instead
of moving data to machine learning
engine why can't I move machine learning
engine closer to data so that was the
whole premise of that the second thing
was skill set gap in industry we just
don't have that many PhD data scientists
to go to advanced machine learning so
our thing was can we just leverage the
skill our audience already has which is
sequel and then make machine learning
available to them and sequel so that's
exactly what we have tried to do is now
bigquery ml is nothing but a sequel
based like machine learning model
creation within bigquery if you have
bigquery you're already using sequel to
analyze data you have queries ready you
understand your data just write two
lines of code on top of it create model
what type of model you want we can Auto
detect models if
you want and then just give us the input
and what you want to predict and for
prediction
you're just saying like you know select
ml dot predict and you can get the
predictions out so that's how easy it is
that to do to machine learning in within
bigquery
one of the things if you if you saw
earlier today was 20th Century Fox where
they talked about how they were able to
predict what audience would are more
likely to come back to a movie to come
back to the newer movie that they're
launching I want to take a different
example right now with geo Tom so why
don't I invite Neil can you please come
on the stage and help us understand what
geotab does come thanks for you yeah so
can you do a quick introduction of
yourself and tell us a bit more about
geo tap sure geo tab is a global leader
in vehicle telematics many people ask
what is vehicle telematics we have a
little device that collects data out of
a vehicle we are in 1.2 million vehicles
we collect all that data and then we
analyze that at massive scale so we
collect information about where the
vehicle is how fast it's moving how the
engine is performing fuel consumption
information with you going over a
pothole with you slammed on brakes and
so you can just imagine the
opportunities that we have generalize
that data to deliver results to our
customers using you know products like
bigquery and machine learning you know
are really massive and so that that's
really what we do awesome can you share
more about your current existing
infrastructure before you enter into
bigquery ml what kind of technology do
you use from Google cloud how does the
business do and then your transition to
bigquery ml we can discuss sure we think
of you know our relationship with Google
as our competitive advantage we have
more than 500 servers in GCE and that
process the data every single piece of
data that the organization generates is
actually pushed up into Google bigquery
and we're a massive use of Google ml and
tensorflow
we use data proc we use products like
kubernetes and anything that gets
announced by Google we very keenly look
at because really the benefit is and it
was it's an understated problem is that
you know when you you first you start
collecting the data you have it in one
place the next part points is if you
want to leverage AI
Enel you have to have that ml close to
where the data is otherwise you spend
your life just moving data around and so
it's been a great relationship and a
great partnership and I know you've been
involved with bigquery ml since we
announced our alpha so I also know you
have a demo so why don't you tell us
what you're going to show in the demo
and then what audience are we targeting
and then show us the demo then sure I'll
do that just to kind of level set we do
have probably the most comprehensive and
largest Big Data set of vehicles in the
world and as I mentioned before this
data set is very very rich it has you
know we know that - ambient air
temperature air pressures we know
whether it's a dangerous intersection we
know a tremendous amount of data so one
of the things that I'm going to show you
here today
is how we have an add-in into our our
standard product our feed management
product but this is this one's focused
more around smart City and what we're
going to do is we're going to use ml to
predict outcomes for safety based on
weather so I'll get tchard and I'll show
you how that all fits together and how
that would mean while you're getting set
up on that the key thing is there's
another key thing will be launching
today is it's GIS alpha so bigquery will
natively support GIS capabilities like
GIS data types within within the data
warehouse we'll talk more about it a bit
later and there's a detail session at
3:15 that we're going to talk about but
I will hand it over to Neil to talk more
about the demo okay super so we'll get
the demo app all right we're up so what
you're seeing over here is a view inside
our product as I mentioned before this
is an add-in this is one of hundreds of
add-ins that are available in the
product this is one really cool one will
be leveraging Google ml and Google G is
that the bigquery GIS features that have
just being announced here that we just
talked about in order to get some really
interesting data and this is just
starting to scratch the surface of where
we can go with this and you can
understand so what you're seeing on the
left hand side is a view of the
dangerous intersections in the Chicago
area so over the last two weeks
and essentially the hot spots are areas
where it's more dangerous now you ask
how could we possibly tell that well we
know we're just about a hundred thousand
accidents a year happening in our pool
of vehicles we know with people slamming
on brakes so if we aggregate that data
we can then look at where are people
having these accidents and where are
people slamming on brakes or dangerous
lane changes and swerving and whatnot so
what happened is the the big data team
which actually sitting here today what
they did is they took the dead and then
they said let's use the public data set
that was available in Google bigquery
around weather data and so we know for a
particular date and time for a
particular location what is the weather
in that location and they used 250
different metrics to analyze and compute
what can we tell about how weather
impacts safety and so they ran this
experiments and I'm going to show you
some results of that so we'll drop let's
say we drop the temperature down to
around freezing and it's to snow and I'm
gonna run the predictive analysis now
alive and then what we see is actually
really interesting some of the areas
that were dangerous before it's still
dangerous but there's been a big change
in the pattern and so we are seeing
things look remarkably different and if
we zoom into areas now now we can start
seeing well where are those dangerous
intersections let's just take one little
area over here where I'm going to zoom
into and we'll find that whenever it
snows we seem to have a dangerous area
near school and so we might consider
what is happening here maybe the parents
are waiting across the road to pick up
the kids and it's snowing and so the
kids are running across the road and so
you get get the circumstance or perhaps
vehicles break down there but the point
is by leveraging ml by leveraging this
data you know cities can now you know
look at what what the infrastructure is
and change the way the roads are set up
in order to keep keep everybody safe ER
and this is really just starting to
scratch the surface of what you can do
when you when you leverage such a
powerful tool like Google bigquery and
Google Mo Thank You Neil this is awesome
thanks a lot I think we're the key thing
is just making the city smarter and
there's having that kind of impact and
you can actually do model generation and
prediction so fast it's just going to
expedite the whole whole solution cream
absolutely one of the key things was how
quickly our team was able to put this
together
there is no coding involved there's no
kubernetes there's no spinning up
magnitudes of service we love any one of
these two but we have sequel people we
love sequel so thanks Neil thanks a lot
there is actually a session at 3:15 to
go deep dive into the Chioda absolution
the GIS capabilities if you are
interested in GIS data types and all
that would be a good session to go to
later today other than that we have also
worked with our partners to go ahead and
give an integrated experience for this
the bigquery ml capability so looker for
example has this end-to-end workflow
that they have built within looker where
you can actually go ahead and pull out a
data set see it in looker views actually
run a prediction run a create a model
within that visualize a prediction and
then actually go ahead and fine-tune
your model from the looker UI itself so
we will be working with more partners to
bring these kind of integrated
capabilities so analysts who are using
these tools can like you know from
within the tools actually do leverage
bigquery ml from from these tools and
make it really easy for creating these
models visualizing the models and all so
yeah looking forward to this going
forward couple of things in bigquery ml
you have linear and more logistical
regression models that are already
available the beta is available so
please go try it give us some more
feedback in there in the beta world a
couple of other things we are also
announcing clustering beta is coming
again I won't be able to go in details
of partitioning clustering key
capabilities just think about it this
way you can do a petabyte scale query
from bigquery you could do it like two
years back you can do it now but with
class partitioning plus clustering you
can reduce the cost drastically because
we the queries are going to be very more
efficient we only access the data what
is required within that cluster or
within that partition so partitioning
plus clustering is going to help you
make your queries way more efficient and
actually reduce cost drastically if you
are using on-demand pricing model
there's a detail session at 3:15 by
Jordan Teague Ani today you should
absolutely go if you are interested in
in that topic later today there are some
there's some amazing demos Jordan does
in that in that session again as we just
quickly touched upon GIS alpha is
available today so think about that the
scenario
that we were hearing from our customers
was all around for example we are in
masks oh nice enter how many within 2
mile radius how many taxis are available
of this region if you want to do that
kind of query historically it's been
like really difficult to do and with
availability of GIS features you can do
that kind of queries directly inside
inside the query now we have some new
connectors that are going live one of
the other key things we are launching is
our new bigquery UI which will give you
capabilities it looks better and it also
has some one-click experiences to go
into data studio and do visualization
and then we'll quickly take a look at
Google sheets integration that's
available so this is an example along
with the GIS capability of like the the
core data types and the ability to query
we also have a visual tool that we are
launching which allows you to go ahead
and visually fire a query and look at
the points on the map because if you're
doing like a query around
hey show me all the points that are in
two mile radius of another point how are
you going to visualize it it's really
difficult so what we worked with our
earth engine team at Google and have
this visual tool that gives you ability
to visualize that data so please take a
look at that again with sheets as I said
a lot of our customers use sheets for
analysis and doing a move data into it
now with Google sheets you haven't
connector for bigquery from within there
you can just click connect to your
bigquery instance pull data in and start
analyzing that visualizing it out of the
box so one of the other key capabilities
making it easy to go do that analysis
connect to the data sets and also that's
been one of our big themes for for for
this year so that's bigquery how do you
make it easy to go ahead and analyze
data on bigquery streaming analytics we
I touched upon it earlier now we have a
whole portfolio of products that allow
you to do that like you can do millions
of event collection from using pub/sub
data flow allows you to do large-scale
data processing you can use cloud ml or
bigquery to go ahead and do analysis on
top of that data right Brightcove is one
of the best examples of this they
literally collect 75 sorry 8,500 years
of video for
month that's seven billion events a day
is what they collect and they use data
flow plus pops up to go ahead and
analyze those videos and and leverage
some great insights from it but it's not
just the Brightcove or travel oka uses
it for e-commerce clickstream collection
and analyzing that cubed is another
example where in retail they are doing
point-of-sale analysis amazing scenarios
with Nintendo in in game analysis in
game utilization of consumables and then
also nest for IOT data so any kind of
large-scale event collection processing
analytics you can use pub/sub dataflow
for that we are actually announcing few
enhancements in that space one of the
big things that we are doing is Python
Python is one of the fastest growing
language in github if you just look at
all the commits and all and we wanted to
make it easy for our Python developers
to do streaming so now we are going to
enable Python streaming capability with
beam so customers can actually build
scalable data pipelines using are using
Python so that's going in beta now so
customers can use that now we also have
dataflow streaming and shuffle
capability it will help you do
large-scale data processing easily auto
scaling capabilities will come with it
there are detailed deep dive sessions on
these that we should check out if you're
interested one of the other things we
were we have done is we have actually
enhanced the performance on and made our
libraries much efficient much more
efficient for pops up in seven different
languages that you can use but in
addition to that we have lot of
customers who love Tosca they are like
hey I use Kafka already I want to
continue using it on GCP what are what
are my options so historically you could
just go ahead and deploy it to yourself
and manage it but what we have now is
with confluent we have a managed Kafka
solution that's available so if you want
to go ahead and use a managed service
for Kafka you can just use confluent
Kafka on GCP and that's that's one of
our one of our strategies is is to work
with our partners to provide these
end-to-end solutions that you can
leverage as as a customer so that that's
a it's already available that that you
can you
can use one of the other things which is
core to our strategy as well as core
belief is this this open source and
being an open cloud and we fundamentally
look at things from sto to kubernetes
that that we are investing in on our
side in big data world we are investing
a lot and in open source technology like
if you look at just big data roadmap
last 15 years the amount of innovation
that Google has driven and made
available before Google Cloud we used to
make this available as paper so that the
industry could learn from all the
research that we had done everything
from Dremel paper to MapReduce to GFS
like all different papers and then we
also are building a lot of these
products based on these these
technologies there are two key product
areas that we have been investing in on
open source side one is data proc it's
managed Hadoop and spark capability as
well as composer composer is fascinating
when it was in private alpha we had more
than thousand customers using it I have
no idea how do you keep it private and
then they have that many customers using
it so it just took off it's based on air
flow Apache air flow and it was just
basically all the customers loved it and
we started seeing am a tremendous
adoption of it here so we are announcing
the GA for composer now so it's already
available you should be able to use it
major enhancements in in our data proc
side auto scaling and custom packages
custom packages allows you with few
clicks to pick top-level Apache projects
that you want to go ahead and deploy now
in data proc that's that's interesting
and auto scaling based on your resource
needs automatically we will scale your
Hadoop clusters Hadoop and spark
Luster's on your behalf and then of
course we announced a few weeks back
that Hortonworks
now supports their infrastructure on GCP
natively so you can use h DP or h DF
directly on GC p with that let me call
upon Michael from blue apron to talk
about how they are using using GC p
Michael
welcome Hayden good beer can do a quick
intro for yourself as well as the
company your role sure absolutely
everyone hope you enjoying the second
day of next Mike I am so blue apron was
founded six years ago with a well the
modest goal and that goal was to
reinvent our worked in this country and
so what we've made some good progress
that is an audacious goal as the visions
are supposed to be and we thought we can
get at this vision by making home
cooking more accessible easier more
affordable for more people in this
country and in doing so we could go out
there work with farmers producers and
make sure that we were investing in
sustainable agriculture you know humane
ways to raise livestock all these
different things so basically what we do
is we send out proportioned seasonal
ingredients to you in a box with the
recipe to make those and we are around
millions of dinner tables in the US
every single night which is a privilege
and one of them so I love blue apron
okay so how is data analytics use that
blue apron so one of the greatest
privileges about working in food I think
that I've learned is that people always
want to tell you what they think we
don't have to really go out and solicit
much customer feedback no as I said you
around people's dinner tables it's of a
personal moment right and it's it's very
intimate and basically I you know we
have a responsibility to listen and as I
said people will Scherz Scherz he'll
tell us what they want in their recipes
we were joking before that all the
recipes have kale in them in the summer
don't ask me to fix that I call so data
is a really core part of how we make our
business decisions and that's not
immediately obvious
if you look at what we do you think oh
you should have a box of food okay so
that's great but actually we are looking
at the customer lifecycle at every stage
and we are ingesting data about what you
like what you you know what recipes
appeal to you what photos appeal to you
what titles appeal to you and we're
building up a profile of what you like
and as I said people tell us how they
feel if you've ever written a comment on
one of our recipes know that a human
being has read it it's awesome
but we can do better right I and what
and what we think is we can build a
virtuous cycle around what we're doing
here and the vision with data and the
way that we that we we think about doing
that is you know just if we use an
example of something that my team does a
lot of which is recipe recommendations
obviously helping people make sure we
put the right recipe in the box that
you're like obviously so if we have
better recommendations we have better
forecasting we have better purchasing we
are going out and sourcing the right
ingredients and the right proteins and
the right dry goods that meet our needs
that is reducing food waste it is
cutting out another part of the another
like middleman in the step right the
supermarket and you know if we did get
better at that we end up saving you know
thousands and thousands of tons of
wasted food right so every like small
change is really important for us in
that in you know at scale it makes a
huge difference
ah and tell me more about your
philosophy around open source software
and how you use it and stuff like that
within the organization right so I you
know I we're on the record is using a
laundry list of GCP services you know
our enterprise data warehouse is
bigquery we use data flow for our
streaming processing we use state
approximation learning we use GCS for
our data like for our prepared features
are trained models all of this stuff
and but a lot of that orchestration we
use air flow for we have been using air
flow from more or less day one that data
engineering existed a blue apron and
it's incredibly important for us because
it helps us ingest information from
outside sources it helps us you know one
other like batch ETL processes it helps
us run our you know batch machine
learning models all of that stuff and
it's actually a key piece of how we we
end up actually serving our batch
machine learning predictions as well you
know we we use air flow to compute you
know 122 million recommendations every
day and we load those up into a little
leveldb artifact that we serve in memory
from our from our services which that's
great because it means we can serve 122
million recommendations daily with you
know about 15 microsecond latency that's
pretty good Wow we can work with that
that's awesome right but open source is
a huge part of that right we got burned
early on by I think the story should be
familiar to everyone who's worked at a
start-up maybe we got burned early on by
vendor lock-in on on certain clouds okay
and you know we've been committed to
open source from the beginning but that
really made us realize oh you know we
have to take open source seriously as an
engineering organization and you know
not end us up not end up in that
position again you know we're not a big
you know we're not a big engineering
organization data engineering for us
were only 15 people we got you know we
got to work on what we have competitive
advantages in and that is not running
air flow our data operations team
managed to do the most recent air flow
1.9 update on our cluster yeah well I
will they are not they do not sleep well
that week so we don't you know if we we
don't want to get locked in and we want
to write it once run it everywhere in
our hybrid cloud and you know when
Google is saying we are committed to an
open cloud that's very important for us
and that's very important because you
know you can compete for business on any
other
dimension but it's not you're locked
into our product right and that's that
matters a lot and then like that's a
good signal to us you know beam beam
spark tensorflow right these are all
things that we have big investments in
and you know if it's open source we can
move it anywhere we like and we're not
we hope you never move them but I get it
you have an option of moving them
wherever perfect uh thanks thanks a lot
Michael any other key metrics that
you've seen of business results you
would like to share before before we
wrap up you can't ask me that on the
weak who know earnings released but no I
mean basically you know we have seen a
huge amount of a huge amount of uptick
in engagement with our product and you
know when we give customers more ways to
give us feedback we get even more
feedback so it's you know it is a really
virtuous cycle there and we're also
using those insights to help our
culinary team and our amazing chefs
basically plan recipes better and so
that's that's a new exciting frontier
for us is using AI to actually provide
feedback from what we know our customers
will like so that on the menu or more
things that you know this something for
everyone and things that people are
going to love that awesome thank you
thanks Michael great thanks thank you so
as you saw when I talk to customers
across the board this whole thing around
open cloud actually resonates a lot
especially keeping the expertise
customers have in spark aduke as well as
with beam what we have done and and
other areas the fourth topic I want to
talk about quickly was visualizing and
activating your data the key thing is
self-service bi is one of the priorities
in various organizations how do you
explore your data yourself like enable
your users to go ahead and explore the
data as well as do collaborative
data-driven decision-making are the
topics that come up in every
conversation I have with with customers
so one of the things if you haven't used
data studio it's a bi tool that's
available highly collaborative it's it's
basically built
collaboration the key thing is with the
new bigquery UI capability that that I
announce if you use the new UI you can
literally do a one click from your query
click once and directly do a
visualization and data exploration so
you can go explore what data set it is
you can blend that data with other
sources like Adwords or something in
pull the data in and you can actually go
ahead and create a report out of it
within seconds like literally you don't
need a specialist to go do that
additionally we also have pre-built
templates that are available now so you
can literally go in and say there's
actually a template I found on cloud
billing so if you want to just visualize
your billing on cloud Google cloud you
can actually have a template for that or
and you want to analyze your AdWords
stuff you have a template for that so
really good capabilities we are also we
also have our data visualization
developer preview that's available where
you can do a d3 based visualizations
create custom visualizations the other
area that we have invested with with one
of our partners trifecta is the data
prep solution so a lot of our customers
want to do data wrangling as analysts
want to go do that visually
data prep actually allows you to go
ahead and visualize your data which may
be in bigquery figure out what anomalies
are there in the data clean that data up
and store it back as we are getting
ready for our GA with with that tool in
the next few months the key thing is we
focused a lot on getting the feedback
from beta and we'll have some key
capabilities available one big area of
enhancements we have done is all around
team based data wrangling how do you
share your recipes copy and share and
copy your flows how do you go ahead and
like you know reuse your custom sample
recipes and stuff like that so a lot of
focus on that focus more on productivity
like how do you go ahead and have quick
shortcuts to the popular items and all
and then we have a completely
comprehensive design which looks much
better and is made more efficient so
that's one of the areas before I jump
into the next one so one of the other
things somebody told me a while back
it's not being good is not enough you
should also do good so we
been working with some nonprofits to see
how we can help democratize our
analytics and machine learning
capabilities in the in the nonprofit
community and so let's run the video of
how precision medicine is using it and
then I will talk more about that can you
take it over
my name is Robert ABS and five and a
half years ago my mother was diagnosed
with Alzheimer's I knew none of the
medications were working the entire time
was a downward spiral and also lost my
grandfather about 25 years ago disease
my family at the time felt like it was
already too late to change the
trajectory of the disease and it breaks
my heart when I hear the same stories
today
the mission for foundation for precision
medicine is to bring AI and health care
together to detect Alzheimer's early if
you can detect Alzheimer's very early on
that is when the disease is most
susceptible to treatment the data that
you have access to are anonymized
electronic health care records we needed
a HIPAA compliance environment which is
why we use Google cloud we're dealing
with hundreds of variables on millions
of patients which generate billions of
lines of data who a cloud enables us to
scale our operations and bigquery Amala
we are able to develop machinery models
faster and utilize our entire data being
a non-profit may rely on our volunteers
across the US and what really enabled us
to do that we wanted them to be able to
apply machining on the data and look at
trends themselves to empower them to
come up with more innovative approaches
to change the progression of the disease
this work is so important to me because
it helps us address this devastating
illness that has no cure I heard
somewhere that they said
don't forget that dots on the plot our
people and we really take that seriously
[Music]
so great example of how precision
medicine is using the data analytics
capability bigquery ml along with other
bigquery features to go ahead and do an
advancement in in their area so what we
were able to do is today we are
announcing data solutions for change
it's a it's a program that we are
launching for nonprofits across the
world where they can go ahead and on
need basis get access to Google cloud
credits along with self training
resources and hands-on enablement as I
said our goal is how do we democratize
analytics and machine learning for
nonprofits around the world and give
these capabilities enhance of
organizations that want to do good in in
the world so that's that's launching
today the other one more thing that we
are launching is visualized 2030 so this
is a collaboration with World Bank
United Nations UN Foundation and other
affiliate organizations where we want to
drive awareness and actions around the
UN sustainable development goals there
are 17 goals within next 12 years we
want to meet and so we basically this is
a storytelling competition for students
from the grad students around the world
where they can go ahead and submit
create visual stories and insights and
actions based on data studio and the
public datasets into bigquery so
bigquery has 70 plus public datasets
that's available that you can go you
start analyzing today so in this you can
go ahead and create these visual stories
and then submit it by end of September
and then we will announce the winners at
the UN world data forum in Dubai in
October so this is one of the things
that we are announcing today we want the
next generation students who are like
earlier we were talking about 80 million
students using using G suite we want to
extend similar capabilities on data
analytics for this this audience so that
they can start analyzing visualizing and
and coming up with insights insights to
go solve along with that one of the
things I do want to talk about is our
partner ecosystem is super
to us we have partners across the board
like from ingestion we have some amazing
partners if you want to get data into
bigquery or different analytics products
that we have we have amazing partners
that that provide those solutions we
have data integration partners we have
partners for visualization you saw a
previous example of looker tableau is a
big partner in that clique they're a
bunch of partners that provide BI tools
as well as a lot of si partners coming
on board to help you with your various
engagements that that you may have so
that's key Google is a leader in the
insights as a platform for a platform as
a service from Forrester and I'm hoping
we'll be recognized more and more in in
different upcoming upcoming reports that
come out the key thing from me is
there's not more information on big data
that's available on the solution please
please take a look at that there are
amazing sessions I highlighted the GIS
one the deep Taiwan on clustering and
all with enterprise data warehouse
beyond enterprise data warehouse by
Jordan T Ghani there are a lot of other
good sessions on big data topics in the
conference please attend them and give
us more feedback thank you everybody
[Applause]
you
[Music]